je vous le disais en titre l'egypte a
extradé aujourd'hui christophe naudin
vers saint domingue
le français était recherché pour son
implication dans l'évasion de deux
pilotes français condamné dans la sphère
air cocaïne
le criminologue et spécialistes de la
sûreté aérienne avait été arrêté le 4
février au caire en raison d'un mandat
d'arrêt émis par la république
dominicaine qui l'accusent comme il l'a
reconnu lui-même d'avoir participé à
l'évasion des deux pilotes français
pascal forêt et bruno d'eau condamné à
20 ans de prison pour trafic de drogue
dans la sphère air cocaïne
nous sommes ce soir en direct avec son
frère éric anodin qui est yvelinois
bonsoir eric naudin vous avez appris
l'extradition
bonsoir vous avez après l'extradition de
votre retard aujourd'hui est ce que vous
attendiez tout d'abord à une telle
décision dès lors que j'ai entendu
parler de mes coups s'ils arrêtent pour
l'évasion or le mandat d'arrêt est
complètement fallacieux puisqu'il était
sous le coup d'un mandat d'arrêt émis
par l'une binicais votre trafic d'êtres
humains et traite de migrants qui sont
des motifs qui n'ont absolument rien à
voir avec tafer qui vaut bien le façon
dont ils risquent d'être jugé par la
suite
vous avez des contacts aujourd'hui avec
le gouvernement ou l'ambassade française
à saint domingue est ce que vous savez
comment ce comment se trouve votre
sphère où il en est et ce qui se passe
exactement
alors actuellement il est en transit qui
les en avion dont il n'est pas encore
arrivé sur le territoire dominicain
je suis entré en contact avec le député
des français de l'étranger sur la zone
caraïbes repli dominicaine et nous
cherchons actuellement à s'assurer deux
des meilleures conditions de détention
pour mon frère et de la meilleure
défense possible voilà et ma belle soeur
la femme de mon frère est en relation
étroite en ce moment avec le milf eid
affaires étrangères pour est fier aussi
de voir ce qu'il est possible de faire
alors vous deviez venir sur notre
plateau ce soir bien sûr nous comprenons
que forcément
voilà vous ayez une est à cette affaire
plus importante à gien quelles vont être
les démarches que vous allez engager à
partir d'aujourd'hui pour essayer
d'aider votre frère il avait des
contacts avec le consul avait des
contacts avec les différends politiques
impliqué donc sénateurs et députés sur
les zones république dominicaine sur des
zones régies parce qu'il ya encore des
choses qui sont fournis sur ce côté là
avec les sénateurs et députés de la
circonscription mobile et mon frère des
relations avec le lissage affaires
étrangères le quai d'orsay pour montrer
aussi que beaucoup de choses dans cette
affaire sont sont floues voire fausses
avec eux
si jamais il était jugé regarde une
justice partiale
il serait probablement pas en train de
risque et 15 à 20 ans de prison pour ce
qu'il a fait et qui l'a récupéré deux
français sur des zones carnage dans les
eaux internationales et les a ramenés en
france c'est compliqué de d'estimé
l'actuelle mégane là dedans même si on
comprend le fondement de la ferme vous
craignez que votre frère pays pour
justement les pilotes qui l'a aidée à
sortir où il complètement que le quai
d'orsay sont voit-il suffisamment à
jouer à son rôle pour protéger peut-être
pour délimiter à votre frère dans cette
affaire aujourd'hui on a réussi à
mobiliser l'état français à partir de
l'année dernier suite à la non de
l'extradition
avant on avait des contacts extrêmement
timide alors je suis bien que nous les
diplomates ne me dise pas tout même s'il
était dans l'élection ne le dirait pas
mais en tout cas le sentiment qu'on a de
l'extérieur c'est très peu de choses
sont faites pas assez et il a maintenant
ni vraiment dans l' angoisse surtout que
mon frère a des preuves de ce conte est
important il est suivi il a été
hospitalisé pendant son en plus tendue
en egypte et on ne sait pas comment se
passera la suite de sa détention
réplique dominicaine vous un atr
président à françois hollande
aujourd'hui on l'a déjà fait je ne fais
pas fille
aujourd'hui ça aura du sens bien
évidemment que si jamais il se mobilise
pleinement
on peut faire beaucoup mais je suis
persuadé que
c'est pas dans son désir se mobiliser
par contre certains politiques plus
proche de république dominicaine avec de
meilleures relations plus sur le terrain
auront sûrement une meilleure écoute
mais aujourd'hui j'ai un mobile à toutes
les volontés que ce soit françois
hollande manuel valls monsieur ayrault
les différends politiques tous ceux qui
sont en capacité de faire quelque chose
et même les particuliers les entreprises
tous ceux qui auraient des relations
qu'ils sont capables de faire entendre
raison à la république dominicaine voilà
j'en mobile à toutes les forces
possibles votre votre communauté ou
comité de soutien justement c'est un peu
votre frère va agir vous allez à faire
des événements organisés des initiatives
très prochainement dans les prochains
jours justement pour pour votre frère
pour l'instant où je vais pas répondre à
la question pour la simple et bonne
raison que l on veut agir le plus
sereinement le plus intelligemment
possible et on voudrait pas en menant
des actions de force se mettre à dos les
politiques qui pourraient nous aider
donc je pense pas honnêtement que ce
soit à l'ordre du jour par contre de
continuer à communiquer on appelait une
page facebook un compte twitter un site
internet de communiquer sur sa situation
et pis de recueillir les soutiens
possibles des gens qui ont des idées
parfois est donc incertain nous emporter
des idées et dit ça c'est important
voilà ce qu'on nous apporte des conseils
nous apporte des choses comme ça ça
c'est important mais aujourd'hui faire
des actions de mobilisation c'est
compliqué on avait une pétition en ligne
par exemple cette pétition commence à
recueillir plusieurs centaines de
signatures
on pense que ça peut avoir du sens si on
amène à nos politiques une pétition qui
est très fourni et qui montre quel
intérêt les français ont pour christophe
naudin qui est quelqu'un qui était déjà
médiatique avant cette histoire et dans
la très bonne avec un très bon enfant il
a fait beaucoup pour la france il a fait
beaucoup pour la sûreté de notre pays
il a été distingué parmi femme
d'intérieur est officier dans les écoles
de police et de gendarmerie
on est papa d'un voyou
voilà enfin je crois que l'état français
aujourd'hui ne tient pas compte
merci beaucoup eric naudin d'avoir
accepté de répondre à nos questions et
de vous être exprimé en duplex merci au
revoir